hello hello hello hello okay focus
everyone focus okay I'm sorry I'm trying
to focus the cab yeah what's your name
sir I'm Sam from New Zealand Oh New
Zealand okay wait wait wait Sam I'm so
sorry
[Applause]
okay so I know really have really gather
yourself okay just go with your story go
with your short so my story actually
involves one of your guests gray and so
yeah my mum's a nurse and she used to
live in London she told me not to tell
the story and she's probably gonna kill
me now
[Applause]
you decide you want to go you go Sam so
your mother told you not to tell the
story helen is in it go she's a Mama's
nurse and she actually used to look
after father for a while when they lived
above the flare and anyway
mom would have a key and should go up
every now and again I think one time she
was actually in the bathroom and she
heard someone singing around singing
around and so she opened the door and
how does dancing our naked dancing yeah
that's where my mum first kind of they
kind of met and you know hello hi hi
what's your name Samantha Samantha
we from Samantha new zealand new zealand
home of the stories that's not really
where what
Samantha I fear this won't last very
long speak as quickly as you like all
right when I had my first job out of uni
I had a call from my manager saying just
to say hi woman's dreams been crushed
just going
I was riveted
[Music]
[Applause]
hi how are you very well thank you
marvelous hey what's your name Maitland
Maitland yes lovely and where you from
Maitland originally Aberdeen originally
where are you now I live in London I'm a
London tour guide oh really what bit of
London are all over it every bit every
bit what is the most interesting thing
in London what is the thing that people
don't normally see that they should the
backstage red chair of Graham Norton's a
long long time ago I used to be a
cocktail barmaid in Aberdeen and in the
late 70s different times you had to wear
dresses that were kind of short and law
and all that jazz I know terrible and
one Christmas bars really really busy
cocktail orders are flying in and you
had to add up the whole round in your
head before you then put everything into
the till has one amount and the till
drawer would then open money in all done
so I've done all that I've put in the
amount of plunged it down and the guy
behind shouts in another order which
means I have to then press a button to
close the till drawer and as I press the
button to close the till drawer the
dangly bits of my uniform gets stuck in
the till shelf which means that my boobs
and then my nipples got trapped
and of course I later a yellow and my
coworker when what's the matter and he's
really loud it's Christmas and the pub
and I had to show my nipples are stuck
[Applause]
hello sir hi there hi what's your name
Ryan Ryan
where you from Ryan I'm from New Zealand
Oh lovely home of the story New Zealand
are you travelling living here for two
years for two just just two years yeah
[Laughter]
I'm an electrician an L trician yeah
okay so I was at a New Year Festival I'd
had a bit too much to drink during the
day in the campground I was walking
along to the festival and I needed to
get rid of a bit of what I drank so so I
hold on a portaloos I ran up to them rip
the door open projectiles Beauty
everywhere then I looked down and I just
spewed all over a guy who was sort of
relieving himself on the low I was about
freaked out first thing that came to
mind he looked angry he was gonna whack
me I gave him a bit of a whack myself
would you couch what's your name it's
Amy where are you from I'm from Northern
Ireland no wasn't hard Amy's not what
played in Northern Ireland a banger
banger loved it's a seaside resort so em
I studied music at University and we
were getting ready for the end of your
concert I play the French horn so I had
a big solo coming out of course and I
stupidly when night the night before and
got very drunk and the next day we were
getting ready for the concert my solo is
coming up and I really did not feel okay
and my solo began and I knew I was gonna
be sick looking around everywhere to see
where I could be sick had to take the
French
[Music]
[Applause]
I had some supplementary questions at
did like did she then played no good
picture wasn't playing the clarinet was
there hello hi what's your name Nick
sorry now Mitch Mitch okay
where you from Mitch I'm from
Philippines okay and do you live here
I'm studying here yeah okay what are you
studying
um social entrepreneurship at Goldsmiths
[Applause]
I was trying so hard nice be nice and
then no I couldn't
so we try another one I may have lost it
hello hi hi what's your name Elizabeth
hello Elizabeth and were you from no
Terry give her a give her a moment I
think I think you're in trouble
what where you from well I'm from Ohio
Ohio okay live here oh you live here
what do you do here well I used to be a
school principal but I'm an education
here still okay teaching people training
teachers oh okay okay board now okay
okay so when I was 12 years old and this
is in the mid 80s I used to get these
Tiger Beat magazines because I had a
Robert Downey jr. board in my bedroom so
I'd get him for the glossy snatch the
board the board was getting it packed so
I had this great idea to wallpaper my
room with Robert Downey jr. glossies and
so I pasted his face all over my bedroom
wall and it looked amazing by the way
anyway my dad came home and went
completely ballistic I mean I got I got
a whoopin that's what I got and we ended
up having to scrape faces of Robert
Downey jr. off of my bedroom wall and it
was absolute carnage because like there
was one I left it was horrible and there
were huge holes in the wall and so my
dad had to spackle the wall he had to
repaint the entire wall this ugly
seafoam color and frankly I blame the
whole ordeal on you Robert Downey jr.
because
that's our etern hi what's your name sir
my name is Nick Nick lovely I'm where
you from Nick I'm from New Zealand well
I live here oh you live here Wednesday
what are you doing here I'm a paramedic
a parent a proper job and everything
okay I'll go with you sorry sir
so when I was a paramedic back in New
Zealand one Sunday afternoon I went to a
guy that chopped three fingers off from
the lawnmower oh and we packaged his
hand up we had to look for his fingers
in the bush and the hitch in everything
like that and we rushed him to hospital
because if they get to hospital in time
they can reattach the fingers and on the
way at a hospital I said you're 40 years
old how do you know not to put your
hands at the bottom of a lawnmower and
he said I was driving home when this
afternoon and I saw that a guy had
picked up the lawnmower turned it on his
side and walked across the front of his
hedge to hospital we walked into recess
to see the surgeon and we walked past
another person and he said hey it's the
guys
[Applause]
hello hello dren how are you I'm nervous
oh don't be sir my name's Ross Ross
lovely and were you from Ross
I'm from Steuben's half a cheer-off you
go we destroy sir
okay so together my wife Sharon we went
on holiday last year to Greece but we
couldn't get to sleep very well for the
first couple of days so decided perhaps
to go to a pharmacy and try and get some
sleeping tablets I went into the chemist
and said have they got this particular
brand of sleeping tablet and the man
behind the counter there sits me what
it's just for sleeping isn't it and I
said yes just just honey did a couple
just for the next couple of nights and
he said but as long as it's just for
sleeping he said I've got these ones
they're not the brand you asked for but
if you take these these will do the
trick so later on that evening my wife
and I went home where to the apartment
and we went to bed my wife was playing
on Facebook which is what she likes to
do before bed and if I'm going to get a
good night's sleep then I'll totally
sleeping's houses so I popped on the
service pops it in and I said to Sharon
I said would you like to have one as
well so we both get a really good
night's sleep will be fresh Bauer so she
took one as well and why didn't he just
tell this story she would have been
right up
[Applause]
looking on the phone and I picks up the
packet I have a little look at it cuz
they look very similar to the temps have
had before and but then I looked at the
pain I couldn't make the head tail of it
but I said Shannon well have a look on
the internet go on this Twitter what it
is and so she she's typing in the name
and then she just went very quiet and I
said well what is it she says well
you've just given us both bloody
rohypnol
[Laughter]
[Applause]
okay okay hypno is a sleeping tablet
sleeping tablets gave us
[Applause]
[Laughter]
[Music]
you